la llamada a emergencias que alertó del
mortal tiroteo del jueves en el plató de
rodaje the best apunta a que tensiones
reinaban entre la producción
tenemos dos heridos por un disparo de
película necesitamos ayuda urgente bien
ya los estamos atendiendo sólo que ese
conmigo en el teléfono
ese maldito asistente de dirección me
gritó en el almuerzo preguntando por las
revisiones este desgraciado lo vieron a
gritarme se supone que debe revisar las
armas es responsable el asistente de
dirección al que se refiere el audio es
del curso un veterano de hollywood la
atención se centra ahora en la
implicación de halls en el protocolo de
seguridad junto con la de la jefa de
manejo de armas ana gutiérrez de 24 años
los registros judiciales muestran que
durante un ensayo hall se entregó el
arma a alec baldwin ambos sin saber que
estaba cargada con munición real había
sido colocada allí por gutiérrez hold
gritó incorrectamente arma fría para
indicar que el arma no contenía balas
reales
entonces disparó matando
involuntariamente a la cinematografía de
42 años felina hitchins e hiriendo al
director joel usa las armas utilizadas
en las producciones cinematográficas
suelen ser armas reales que pueden
disparar balas o balas de fogueo no está
claro porque este arma contenía munición
real había sido preparada por gutiérrez
según los ángeles times previo al
incidente al doble de ball wing
accidentalmente también disparó balas
reales cuando le habían dicho que al
arma no estaba cargada las tensiones en
el plató de la película habrían
comenzado desde principios de octubre y
llevó a siete miembros del equipo a
abandonar el set unas horas antes de que
sheen fuera asesinada les preocupaba una
serie de cuestiones desde su alojamiento
hasta procedimientos de seguridad